good morning dear colleagues welcome to
the second day of the eleventh annual
Assembly of the Eastern Partnership
civil society forum allow me to open the
high-level session of the second day and
today we have a special guest for the
high-level session so allow me to
present the newly appointed Commissioner
for neighbourhood and enlargement mr.
Oliver mahi welcome
[Applause]
so you're a guilt dear Commissioner and
Sara total bedlam
this is difficult but very nice
congratulations on your appointment as a
new commissioner of the junior of
neighbourhood and enlargement so during
these days we are talking about the
perspectives and the future of the
Eastern Partnership and of course we the
six countries would like to know more
about the future to know about our
perspectives we are six countries with
different bases of implementing the
European reforms
some of us want integration some of us
want to implement the core values of the
European Union which are rule of law
democracy with governance and human
rights and we all stand for it and we
know that your experience is very
valuable in this sense because you were
a part of the Hungarian team which made
Hungary a member of the European Union
and you know all the instruments how to
make this happening in the Western
Balkans especially for North Macedonia
and Albania so you know all the
instruments and we are sure that those
instruments need to be applied in the
Eastern Partnership countries as well so
we here as a civil society forum stand
for the same values and work 24 out of
24 to implement them in our countries
and we are sure that civil society needs
to have more opportunities during the
next years of Eastern Partnership to be
able to influence the implementation and
the pace
of the implementation of the European
reforms in the Eastern Partnership
countries and thank you very much for
starting your mandate with the speech at
the 11th annual Assembly of the Eastern
Partnership civil society forum so we
would like to hear your speech which
will be followed by a short Q&A session
thank you good morning thank you very
much for the very kind Hungarian words
must have been a bit of training for you
to be able to speak the language I'm
truly honored to to open the 11th
Assembly of the Eastern Partnership
civil society forum very shortly after
my appointment as commissioner for
neighbourhood and enlargement let me
start by reassuring you on the
importance I attach to civil society
engagement and rule of law I firmly
believe that an empowered civil society
is key for strengthening democracy
public accountability the advancement of
human rights and resilience working with
the Eastern Partnership civil society
forum and the organizations you
represent will be a key priority during
my five-year mandate civic engagement is
crucial in this respect and it will
continue to be reflected in the EU s
political and financial commitments
bilateral and multilateral arrangements
and reflecting the union's interest in
values as well as the partner partners
policy choices let me stress that the EU
is committed to supporting all six
partner countries reforms and their
sovereign policy choices civil society
has an important role to play in this
process now and also in the future
the current multi-annual financial
framework
as for seeing 300 million euros for
civil society support which has provided
capacity-building
to over 1,000 organizations including at
local level and for local initiatives
strengthened involvement of the civil
society at all stages of policymaking
ladies and gentlemen I'm taking office
as we conclude the structured
consultation launched earlier this year
to take stock of the achievements and
challenges and I and identified the
priorities for cooperation with the
Eastern Partnership countries this
morning I firstly would like to provide
you with some of the main findings of
the consultation second and based on the
consultation I would like to show to set
out some first thoughts ideas we look to
build together the future of our Eastern
Partnership policy framework and thirdly
and most importantly in this forum share
our ideas on the crucial role of vibrant
civil society in shaping and
implementing the Eastern Partnership
agenda on the outcome of the structured
consultation of the Eastern Partnership
agenda we have received over 200
contributions from a very broad
cross-section of stakeholders from
member states and partner countries
including various levels of government
civil society think tanks private sector
as well as international actors first of
all let me thank you
in particular for the work done within
the civil society forum including focus
group discussions in each partner
country and for the written
contributions already received let me
share three key outcomes with you first
is that we see a strong consensus that
the current Eastern Partnership policy
framework the 20 deliverables for 2020
is a good basis on which to build and
continue working the partnership jointly
owned and
result-oriented reform agenda is widely
appreciated by both Member States and
the Eastern Partnership countries and
across the range of all the stakeholders
second there is a broad consensus that
we are delivering on stronger economy
stronger connectivity and stronger
society thirdly as regards stronger
government's many challenges still
remain in some countries we see the
space for civil society shrinking a
solid majority of stakeholders including
civil society member states and partner
countries explicitly mentioned the need
to step up work on rule of law the fight
against corruption and the role of
independent media and civil society in
order to achieve more and more lasting
results the goal to tackle these
important outstanding challenges is
central point of my mission it is key
for citizens who need and demand
transparency and accountable governance
in their day-to-day life
moreover further progress in the rule of
law is instinctively linked to create
sustainable jobs growth and
opportunities for all a favorable
business environment capable to attract
investment requires transparency
predictability independent efficient and
accountable judiciary on the next steps
the consultation provides clear
directions for our future joint work
based on the consultation and in close
cooperation with high representative
Joseph Borel I intend to propose shortly
a framework of ambitious but realistic
objectives for the next mandate in
designing a future-proof policy
framework that keeps the Eastern
Partnership relevant and inclusive for
the years to come your input will be key
I hope we can endorse this new framework
at the next Eastern Partnership summit
likely to take place in June here in
Brussels
finally let me underline the importance
of civic civil engagement and the role
of vibrant civil society in the Eastern
Partnership today and tomorrow they are
key to monitor public actions and also
to assist democratic and socio-economic
reforms going forward I would work to
ensure we move from financing and
supporting actively being gay from
financing to supporting to actively
engaging with civil society to that
effect the EU will sign framework
partnership agreements with the key
civil society organizations which I
trust will ensure an even closer and
more fruitful cooperation reaching a
large spectrum of actors and deliver
better services to citizens I would also
like to engage more with the youth as
many of you know the EU has benefited
and empowered many young leaders during
my mandate I will work to upscale our
targeted civil society fellowship
program to enhance its outreach and
potential in conclusion let me stress
that we have a joint interest for the
benefit of our people to ensure the
insta partnership remains robust
inclusive and relevant it is important
that it remains attractive for all
partners and therefore we need to
continue finding the right balance
between inclusivity and differentiation
what is even more important though is
ownership I am confident that today's
event will provide further input on how
we can work better together to deliver
concrete benefits to citizens in the
Eastern Partnership thank you very much
for your attention and I wish you
fruitful discussions throughout the
annual assembly thank you very much
Oh Sonam seven dear Commissioner for
your honest speech and for the
engagement in continuing the
implementation of the reforms so much
waited by the citizens of the Eastern
Partnership countries when I started the
session I was saying that some of the
countries are implementing quicker the
European reforms some of the countries
are behind so there is a different pace
of implementing the European reforms so
staying in the seat I'd like to reserve
the possibility to ask you the first
question of how it would be possible to
in the context of differentiation and
inclusivity to help the countries with
quicker pace of implementing the
European reforms to achieve even more
instruments because you know there is a
discussion between the three countries
of the Eastern Partnership which
scientist OSI Asian Agreement and the
Ukraine is taking a lead in this process
to form different kind of formats within
the Eastern Partnership because we would
like to keep this format and we are sure
that it will bring very good results
into the region to be able to foster the
implementation of the European reforms
because you see the process it is always
a different situation even in these
countries sometimes backsliding
sometimes progressing so how could we
assure that these countries receive even
more support from the European Union
that would be my first question thank
you thank you very much for the question
we have a very simple approach to
whoever wants to engage more with us we
are ready to engage more of course in
the Eastern Partnership countries we
have very different levels of
cooperation of existing cooperation we
have three Eastern Partnership countries
who have signed a DC FTA with the
European Union that agreement already
foresees a very large scale of
possibilities to integrate these
countries in terms of values in terms of
markets in terms of trade in terms of
connectivity so there's a huge
opportunity still to be tapped from
these agreements we see that these
agreements foresee taking over almost
70% of all the EU law the body of the EU
are key there is a significant alignment
to our policies but of course if we have
if we have additional requests from
these countries we'll be more than happy
to to go further but the same applies to
the other three countries so it's not
going to be dependent on us it is always
dependent on them on the other hand I
still see major room for implementation
of the DC FTA so we can for instance
start by speeding up the implementation
of the DC FTA but we will be having
tailor-made approaches country by
country depending on the needs depending
on the aspirations depending on on the
policy they would like to pursue thank
you so I'd like to take some questions
from the audience with
so thank you so much for a nice speech
my name is circus drive and first of all
I'm really happy to hear that you
emphasize the needs to strengthen the
civil society and to listen to the voice
of the support ship civil society forum
and it's a very nice summary of the main
four conclusions from the structure
consultation it's nice to see what like
the main takeaways from that once but
now when it's 2019 and soon 2020 and 20
deliverables for 2020 is soon coming to
an end I think we all would like to know
what would be your like main focus areas
for the future to see in the upcoming
deliverables if that will be based on
those four like takeaways from the
consultation process and in that case
what kind of actions will you take in
order to emphasize that they are
implemented well and also when you
mentioned youth for example and start
and strengthen the support to civil
society will that also be part of these
new deliverables maybe I was like I use
as an own pillar or like what would be
your main focus areas thank you thank
you for the question I might not be able
to answer all of it because we do not
have such a detailed plan as yet as I
said we're just about to conclude the
consultation but as I said in the speech
what we see is there is the recurrence
of the different priority areas which we
will need to which we will need to
strengthen needless to say rule of law
fundamental freedoms including the
freedom of the press is there's a
headline that we will continue and and
where we need to rely on the civil
society organizations present in the
Eastern Partnership countries
we see youth as as a new priority which
could be a known priority for two
reasons first of all the youth is the
most active part maybe in in civil
society so if we really want to revive
civil society in these countries we need
to build on youth this is one part why
we are thinking about this but there's
another one which is that one of my own
priorities is is to try to create an
economy a sound reliable robust economy
for these countries one of their main
vulnerabilities is the lack of a solid
reliable economy that works for the
people and that creates growth and jobs
locally for the people of these
countries and in that youth is the key
Youth without youth it's not possible to
to create that we see that quite a
significant part of the youth from these
countries have left the country we need
to do everything - RIA track them to
help them to get back and to get a
decent living bead economically be it
security wise be it fundamental freedom
wise so this is why use is going to be a
focal point thank you very much Lasha
please
Oh mr. commissioner my name is Lucia -
Lucia from Georgia I'm sure know that
people of Georgia Ukraine and Moldova
have European aspiration membership
aspiration and for a long time we are
knocking on door to give us membership
perspective I'd like to say it's really
very crucial - to us to our societies to
our citizens and my question is what do
you think what do you think about and
one more issue away yesterday signed
memorandum of cooperation between civil
society organizations of Georgia Moldova
and Ukraine I'd like to give you this
text I think it's very important too
the question yes yeah this this was the
question about the European perspective
yes on the European perspective as you
know according to the treaties any
European country can apply for
membership so it is for Georgia to judge
whether it would like to apply for a
membership currently we have not been
discussing this in the European Union
but what I see as a first step towards
that would be the implementation of the
of the DC FTA that you have the closer
you bring your country in terms of
policies the closer you're going to get
to be able to apply for membership so
European perspective starts with an
application for membership of course it
would also mean that when applying you
would need to demonstrate that you are
closely linked and that you're very
closely very closely oriented with the
EU Thank You commissioner um next
question
okay hello my name is Mikayla Venson I'm
from Armenia original partnership
foundation machinery thank you very much
for your your words about the necessity
to involve society in all the process of
implementation of this in partnership
and in continuation actually of this
conversation since you also mentioned
necessity to build up on what we have
from the 20 deliverers of 2020 I wanted
to mention that in fact one of the
probably weak parts of the 20
deliverables was the fact that the
engagement of the civil society was not
clearly articulated as a deliverable it
was formulated as a cross-cutting thing
but it was never clearly formulated
deliverable so in this respect
in continuation with my colleagues
question who do you think that it will
be possible to make this formulation of
engagement of civil society in the
implementation of the Eastern
Partnership as a deliverable that that
will be afterwards reported thank you
very much this is certainly something I
would take back I take it as part of the
of the consultation and we will reflect
on that but as I said also in the in the
speech civil society we need them to be
on the ground also for us to get second
opinions so of course it is very
important that we have strong civil
society organizations throughout the
Eastern Partnership this is something we
can we can we can consider and we should
be able to get back to you thank you
very much should we take one more
question
I think last question please thank you
very much I'm sorry are coming from
Azerbaijan first of all I wish you best
of luck and the during next five years I
would like to draw your attention on
specific issues that concerns us too
much in fact recently mr. president lef
and stated officially in his speech held
in Baku State University we will never
integrate towards Europe as there is no
difference between men and women what do
you think about this statement as a
commissioner thank you
well first of all I don't know the
statement so I would I would I would
need to our need to look into the
statement second there are quite a
number of statements made by my
statement who who could raise questions
but if you want I can I can look it up
for you
of course equality between men and women
is not only the European value it's a
universal value so I don't quite see the
link between the two
you would have to respect that in the
globe one question but we will have more
opportunities because as I said there
was the last question one yeah we know
we know
Belarus very short please very short
please
dear Commissioner thank you for a
position and you said that you that it's
important to have six countries on the
board and the Belarusian civil society
we a bit worrying about the protesters
was going in towards these integration
processes between Russia and the other
is it ongoing now and the question to
you do you have a position regarding
this initiative from the Russia to
integrate Belarus more deeper because it
might enlarge their position to other
Eastern Partnership countries how you
see what should the EU do in this regard
thank you
so far so far the the EU has no position
on this we need to look into how is it
approached if this is on the basis of a
mutual agreement between two states it
is very difficult to to question it from
the EU if this is done in a different
way and not so peaceful way let me put
it this way or force is used not
military force but other force and
influence is used of course we need to
look into it and we will have an opinion
on that but first I see many many news
and many news contradicting the the
other ones first I would like to see
clearly what is really going on as I
said if this is on the basis of a mutual
agreement it will be very difficult to
to argue the choice of third countries
to create further integration or even
joining one another but as I said we
were looking we will be looking at this
on the basis of very clear international
law standards thank you thank you very
much dear Commission are very difficult
questions and there are many more to be
asked and answered we hope for a very
close cooperation
I believe me we are your friends in the
European agenda which we want to be
implemented in our countries and we hope
for a very very strong cooperation in
the next four years with you so good
luck good luck on your job and personal
[Applause]
okay so now when we announce the next
panel and and I invite Natalia yes to
announce the next panel